profesor buenas noches gracias por estar
con nosotros en france 24 le pregunto
por el balance del gobierno de angela
merkel
o yo creo es un empate más o menos son
dos puntos centrales durante su tiempo
que destacan el primero es la crisis de
2009 y rescate del euro donde siguió una
política no muy ruidoso pero muy
enfocado muy pragmático para rescatar el
oro un proyecto nuevo en estos días
todavía y para unir otra vez y más a los
las naciones europeas especialmente con
grecia y la crisis en españa profesor yo
creo eso es un plus que en la otra cosa
es la crisis de los refugiados en 2015
cuando un millón de gente más o menos
desconocido verdad entraron al país
durante unas pocas semanas y eso era una
cosa que estaba muy cuestionado no
solamente en alemania pero en turno de
ropa por las fronteras abiertas que
tenemos entonces yo creo es un empate
más o menos ahora le pregunto de los
aciertos de la canciller merkel y
también las deudas pendientes en
términos políticos
en términos políticos yo creo su
proyecto político central era abrir el
conservatismo hacia las nuevas clases
urbanas académicas femeninas feministas
y
y abrirlo para acá para hacer el
conservatismo para el futuro
y eso ha dejado los conservadores
tradicionales
al lado marginalizado y tenemos una
nueva partida un nuevo partido político
de la nueva y de la nueva derecha como
en otros países versiones en en
inglaterra bolsonaro aquí en el brasil
el presidente trump hasta en enero
entonces yo creo no a lograr esto es
todavía y digamos la orientación del
conservatismo no es bien claro eso es
algo que queda por hacer